hey everyone Avengers infinity Juarez
held some early screenings and we got
our first reactions
what are these lucky bastards saying
about the movies story tone and Hawkeye
saturation are they gonna keep all those
sweet sweet danos deep give us a taste
we need those Thanos states they help us
feel alive okay okay wait how long was I
out guys welcome to new Carstairs news
our deep dive into all the biggest
stories this week so in addition to of
interested busy work we're gonna talk
about Star Wars Episode nine and the
doctor changed sequels some Rick and
Morty news more we got it we got
everything you need to know I'm Erik
Bosse and joining me at this table are
over here is a Sam basher how's it going
great Phillip Melina how are you good I
it's Morty but before we get to that
let's start with our top story guys
early reactions to Avengers infinity war
Marvel Studios is showing the first 30
minutes of the movie to fans and press
over the next few weeks included screens
in London I will do anything to get
anything if you have a whole day on your
imagination make it tend to have to
worse a miracle do it but only if you
make it ten times worse no that's boiler
warning if you don't want to know
anything we don't really have any
information except for the script but if
you're worried that our speculation
might ruin the fun mine's the one
subscribe now
those in attendance weren't allowed to
tweet much but here's what they did say
they called it ambitious and that the
movie switches tones between different
groups like the Guardians sequence had a
different look and feel and sound
tracked in the New York scenes they also
described it as very funny and they said
that Hawkeye is still in my a Oh
meanwhile lots of people are reacting to
ebony ma the member of the Anna's Black
Order who sent needs to break out new
characters things very very fun to watch
now the directors the Russo brothers are
taking spoilers and leaks very seriously
they tweeted this week a memo hestian
fans who see it early to maintain quote
the highest level of secrecy and do not
spoil anything and they use the hashtag
Thanos demands your silence this is
awesome also a Funny or Die released a
very funny parody of this letter that I
highly recommend you read it's great now
it's a little rare to see this kind of
effort by filmmakers to keep a lid on a
movie sometimes the director like JJ
Abrams will just simply refuse to do
advanced screenings and carefully edit
their own trailers to keep us guessing
what's in the movie I have to do the
last junket for the last Jedi we didn't
get to see the movie before we
interviewed them we just like sorry how
is it there like we can't talk about it
oh so so that's becoming more and more
common but for like to do these creative
things by directors to take these steps
to like beg us to not talk it feels very
old-school like I remember seeing some
old trailer for psycho by Hitchcock and
where Hitchcock came out and said please
do not tow people just move because
apparently like back in those days
people just show up twenty or thirty
minutes late to a movie and people just
talk about and he like that that works
like people did not without spoiling
psycho that movie takes if you didn't
know it takes this huge turn like 20
minutes in it's like oh this is a
completely different movie and thing
happens with scream screaming they also
had to hide that with the drew Barrymore
yeah her character was prominent on the
poster yeah right like putting a huge
person on the post for the movie and
who's not a main part of movie so this
it feels very old school but also
uncommon and new in a new way to do this
but so what do you what do you guys
think about these reactions and without
going too deep into our prediction
because you know we don't want to
accidentally spoil anything what kind of
twist what kind of twist do you think
would necessitate such a huge effort by
the filmmakers to tell us not to say
anything yes man sure dad but right but
like is it something that because I
think we're all expecting death right
like this has been what we've been
leading up to what kind of game changer
would this death have to be to keep us
from wanting to talk about all of them
your analogy with the drew Barrymore
scream the biggest people on the poster
maybe other smoking gonna be a for
Fantastic Four it's gonna live that
little lower point yep supporting it in
my heart I feel like cap ain't gonna do
too well at this movie okay yeah this is
the one that stars Tom on a contract
right know both movies yeah yeah but
Robert Downey jr. is only who also Chris
Evans said in an interview he's like no
Avengers this one and for I'm done like
that's it that's all I'm yeah they shot
that at the same time as this so it was
really tough because okay have we we've
addressed the thing that is very likely
to happen in one of these Avengers
movies in the next two getting the big
thing that's fascinating about all the
old movies
we we've hinted at it this before it
could work yeah okay so this is
potentially a spoiler for infinity war
one or two but it could be what they're
trying to hide but it's kind of out
there too so if you don't want to know
maybe if we can put a timecode down and
you can just skip ahead but it's that
there might be time travel in this movie
where they revisit the previous films
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe like
all of them like going back to you know
the first of the first avenger which is
kneecaps america movie like literally go
back to intervene in that movie I guess
they're they need to get their parents
back together right back to the beach
Rebecca future part two things I'd
always be at yeah
yeah yeah great but all of the movies
might get revisited and I think if they
do that first of all I thought that
would be in the second one mhm so that's
why I'm not even sure if that's what
they're trying to hide in this first one
but also I think it'd be just side note
a great way to launch into the new phase
where they kind of reboot things now and
it's like now we have an explanation why
Robert Downey jr. is a different person
oh yeah you know could be also really
cool as if they x-men whatever the
business you could yeah you could go
back something happens like getting
exposed to cosmic garbage whatever like
makes its time but like but like but
like because people are exposed to some
radiation like people start to evolve
and you get x-men and present-day duh
yeah I could see a version of this movie
where like you know some kind of ending
is like we have to go back to the
beginning you know and then we we see
Iron Man visiting himself in the cave in
Afghanistan a river that was right like
and then all of the vendors for happens
in that dark cave it's really cool to
see them all together in so much much
Thor to Iron Man 2 yeah and that's yeah
I think if we're gonna see something
like that some kind of huge game changer
because I think death is just the
beginning
and release those movies with the edits
we're gonna see I think yeah we're
definitely in store for a major
character going away sure but I think
you're right that it's probably beyond a
character Dez it's got to be a game
changer if the the most similar moment
right now is Steven Spielberg recently
at South High with the premiere of ready
player one with the huge sequence in the
middle that again if you haven't seen
ready player one yet you have to go see
just for this sequence in the middle
it's when my favorite things happen in
years and movies I think it's got to be
at that level so you see the Spielberg
told everyone in the crowd wasn't that
great don't tell anyone please
it's the same kind of thing I think it's
gotta be at that level yeah you got to
put yourself in the minds of the Russo
brothers when they're working with the
the screenwriters and the marvel folks
and Feige sitting around a table saying
like oh this would be really fun let's
make sure this happens oh but you know
what that's gonna be really hard to keep
looking new rockstars
ruining movies according to Hollywood
Reporter right yeah it's got to take
some kind of crazy thing for them to say
you know it okay a month out from the
movie we'll just tweet out to people be
cool anything well also this is like is
this like the first movie where most of
the cast didn't get the script like the
whole script there silently Don Cheadle
said the same thing he was like I don't
know I just came to chop my stuff and
then I bounced and it was like easy but
like and he's like I'm excited to watch
it because I'm gonna be able to watch it
just like all of you guys what if they
go back and it's Terrence Howard did he
say bounce because that could have been
did he wink when he said no and then I
bounced like cuz he hits the ground
again go back in time and then black
dancer tiptoes over to his like body on
the ground and I put those in the back
earlier yeah I mean that's not a
horrible reason to go back in time to
fix something if you're gonna do it but
then you have to fix every person who's
in a wheelchair we're gonna go full a
sci-fi here Hawk I got weird time-travel
garbagey whatever storylines and he is
now all of time and space he's the arrow
that starts that touches the beginning
and the end that's where he is right now
explanation is it makes sense I think ya
got a video did not to jump ahead too
much but really exploring where Hawkeye
actually could be and we'll add that to
the list thank you I mean you'll have to
now I said it so you
good then we won't talk about that every
guy's a dad well for sure he has a
newborn from major Voltron but that's
like his story it's just him being a dad
and he's just dropping without his shirt
on over and over again so I need that's
the fourth movie yeah because I think
that is the big question like granted
seen only the first 30 minutes they the
first act doesn't have to show you
everything that happens movie it sounds
like there are multiple movies in one
here and who knows that those first 30
minutes that Marvel showed people is
what is gonna be my final cut of the
movie but I think according to the
directors you know they aren't showing
Hawkeye and the posters and and and
trailers for a specific reason trying to
get people to care more about you he's
like I'm not buying but also a boss
logic who does all those awesome faint
edits for every genre they he's like
don't worry ant man's on this poster and
he zoomed in really close to the thumb
on the gauntlet and there's like a
little shape there and it's not a rock
but like he edited it in and it's just
ant-man like like on the side so it's
like hey guys now we're just missing
Hawkeye we're really close now real real
quick just to acknowledge what they
actually said those first 30 minutes are
like what do you guys think of the fact
that the of the tonal shift so you know
this is trying to bring together 18
movies in one and as we know you know
Thor is very different from you know cap
is different from Iron Man which is
different from guardians guardians
obviously kind of started to infect
things like thor ragnarok wasn't very
Guardians asked yes like you know the
fact that it sounds like they're kind of
segmenting it a little bit making it
feel like each other movies what do you
guys think about that
I'm personally I'm fine with that I
think that makes it it definitely will
keep things moving since you have to
move through so much plot as long as it
doesn't all start to like blend together
you're like I don't I don't I think we
have three of the stones now I have no
idea but as long as it feels different
it's like okay this story is ending now
and we're coming together to make this
story work now and also you got a taste
of like what those genres would be like
when I come together we had star-lord
talking at iron man you're like the way
star-lord stalks ascends like a teenager
talking and but an Iron Man
reacts like equal to that so I'm I'm
excited for I'm glad they're doing it in
a different way I think it'll help the
storytelling for you to keep up because
there is so much going on and then I
think that's why they've used the
posters with the different colors and
the groupings so you can already get a
headspace going right this is who's
gonna be together this is who's gonna be
together and the different colors you
know kind of shows that they're doing
different tones throughout it all yeah
they actually are placed with like the
people that are from the trailers we
know they tend to spend their story with
and there's nothing there there's a
green one that's six segments here could
correspond to six different Infinity
stones with kind of separate I don't
know I I think music is also a great way
to do that too like we saw how
successful John Williams's score was in
the last Jedi and the way that he was
able to use like different musical like
motifs and and just use music as a way
to like tell this part of the story and
the the music of kylo Ren de Steel's so
distinctly different from the music of
Leia you know and and how by using music
and and by tweaking it in several
different ways they're able to like tell
different stories at once at all feel
part of the same macro story so it
they're able to use mute I mean the the
Marvel Universe isn't known for its
musical scoring as well and personally
but I agree black panther really good
job that was the first one this is
Charlotte's I just want to point that
out that is one of my faith they've just
released the soundtrack if you want to
listen to it's very very good yeah for
sure and I think if they can build on
that that the way the successes that
they had with with Black Panther and
using music to group everything together
in different ways you've got your
compositions and using a composer and
then you have like with guardians it's
just a soundtrack like yeah you know it
songs that are getting you in that vibe
mm-hmm um the the thing I'm worried
about with this feedback is the word
ambitious used in good ways and in bad
ways but yeah it's like when you know
like sometimes when you have like that
friend who's really artistic and they do
their one-man show and you're like it's
ambitious you're very creative very
creative you guys were all there right
like the lights are really bright but I
heard three people clap in and
it's really good water it's fine usually
I use ambitious in a way where it's like
man they tried they tried there's a lot
and they gave it a go but it's in 30
minutes they don't know I guess whether
or not it's gonna pay off so yeah well
that's only a tenth of the movie you
know what's funny is do you guys
remember how much concern there was
around Civil War it's like how will they
balance all of these characters is it
great and and but also I remember we we
talked a lot about how they cut out a
lot of characters though but that
conversation is not happening that much
and look I mean this one is gonna be
like way more difficult to balance so
that's actually I'm curious about if
they're doing like that was the idea
let's separate it into like separate
movies and between each separate movie
we'll get up meanwhile and then it'll
cut to the other one like comic panels
meanwhile at the Legion of Doom or
whether it's from the Superfriends
cartoon yeah yeah I think humor is like
images I I agree like you know people
use ambitious to describe like The Dark
Knight Rises and in the last Jedi two
movies that are both really liked but
for some people they're like too big for
its britches but hearing that it's so
funny I think humor can be like a good
remedy for anything for sure and as long
if the jokes I'll feel like they're from
the same movie then like I don't want to
be too funny but the war was a good
balance of both them yeah if you can you
can use it as just like in the right
moment to the right time second just
like win the audience back even the
darkest darkest movies I'm yawning too
soon it doesn't stay with me and I want
this Civil War though is it's have you
watched it don't know but I want to I
would actually really really want to and
I do not have that for a lot of the DC
movies who don't opt yeah but you know
what do you want to rewatch like well I
rewatched Batman vs Superman and I loved
it a lot more I rewatched it yes I want
to I want to watch Justice League again
before I want to re-watch Thor Ragnarok
I know most of you guys Amaro and I love
Marvel people and I love the more
I love Marvel comic people but the but
but rewatch I feel like there's there's
more meat there in terms of it like I
feel like I enjoyed thor ragnarok so
much first time I watch it and I don't
need to see it again I don't want to
find something to dislike about it was
very very funny so I miss it and i was
a-sayin healing yay and I watched it
with the Kiwi and he's just like how is
how is like our local humor in a giant
ball town hate is for like maybe thirty
million people and that's it like a
billion you know how many we got five
well there's six people in this room
just more who than who's at my
one-person show I'm just want to say
it's a one-person show because that's
2018 but Russo brothers boiled down the
characters in Civil War to their essence
and nailed it they made vision
interesting because after age of Ultron
we watched it recently
that's Jessa tour to get through that's
a really hard movie to get through and I
know by the end of it he's like phasing
through people and you're like wow and
they don't explain in the Civil War but
it doesn't matter because you get this
great moment where he explains this is
how he sees the world and this is how he
understands himself it happens within
three lines and I'm like cool I get it
and same with Scarlet Witch I was like
okay you're nuts you're proud of who you
are now but everyone around you scared
of you and you don't care and like it's
like that's amazing
that age of Ultron was a movie dedicated
to you and I didn't get that from there
but in civil war where you're sharing
the screen with at least half of these
people and I was able to learn more
about you in those scenes so they got it
well so Civil War did well it was like
playing up to everyone's essence and now
it's like because you know them so well
we're gonna mess with it and put it with
people that you like Wow
I do wish though one of the coolest
parts of civil war is whenever Queens
pops up cuz you're like spider-man and
that was so cool the theaters and
there's none of that in this
it's like guardians are gonna show up me
like a but it's like what if it was like
Manchester New York and everyone's like
huh and then like the x-mansion like oh
yeah I forgot that's where they live
yeah
imagine if that's the thing they're
trying to hide and everyone just know
that you're able to talk to Fox into
they time travel and then all of a
sudden there's a Star Destroyer that
goes by well let us know what you're
most looking forward to what your
reactions are to these to these initial
reactions and I think I'm super excited
we really touch on evany ma yet but if
you watch our breakdown of the black
order it there's a lot of interesting it
was really good yeah I mean aside from
me misidentifying the mocap actor as
British when he's actually Irish
apologizing and but you know whatever I
own up to it and thank you for pointing
out clearly Irish I'm really excited to
see you I'm super excited about fan OHS
but I'm very excited to see yet another
good villain in this world so anyway let
us know what you're most excited about
and and we will see hopefully we'll be
able to get and see this movie early
again we will do anything to do it well
let's move on to update here okay now
since this is a new boxers news we want
to cover all the news you need to know
about we had that date on Doctor Strange
to this week the screenwriter confer TW
oh yeah two two two and it we got
strange to to @eo
we also got that information anyway
would explore Baron Mordo
Giavotella age of fours character and at
the villain would be nightmare just
something that would be it's something
that he wants to explore in this the
Doctor Strange comics in the doctor
George promised nightmare is an entity
from the dream realm who feeds on the
psychic energy of created by people who
are having nightmares isn't that it's
you
type remissive and Nightmare on Elm
Street and the sorry barons yeah it's
also something a little bit yeah yeah so
yeah we're very excited about this and
it's not approved yet I think they're
they're being hush-hush about what exact
future movies there will be in the Sam
we'll see what happens with the future
this hopefully these will happen as soon
as infinity work comes out they'll just
tell it's exactly what the future of the
MCU wait where's your hype meter for
Doctor Strange dude it hasn't been
confirmed some a little bit nervous for
it but height meter if we're gonna do it
100% so right here 100% is over there
it's over here starting over okay well
speak estranged he actually inspires
this week's trivia quiz not branded
water can I drink enough water from
there in the fridge thank you
what's the question trivia question as I
says Doctor Strange inspired in Doctor
Strange when Stephen strange arrives at
Kumar Taj what is the Wi-Fi password
that Baron Mordo gives him he's just
Martin Amis Baron Mordo yet but Wi-Fi
password is what we're looking for here
thank you
well we have all of our answers here now
and as always the winner has decided by
our judges will get to do our weekly in
other news signing off headline or
they'll get to say them while the loser
will have to be funny at the end of
those things it's you know it's always a
challenge for the four of you actually
stick around to the end of the videos
you would know what normally happens for
the rest of you is stick around though
we'll find out okay well let us move on
to some other big news that we got this
week guys
Star Wars Episode nine and the question
of what they'll do about the character
of Leia Mark Hamill was asked about the
idea of
casting the role after carrie fisher's
unfortunate death or perhaps using cgi
to create the performance as Star Wars
movies have done in the past as with
Peter Cushing as Tarkin and rogue one or
even Carrie Fisher's younger self at the
end of that movie Hamill responded that
he thought it would be tough recasting
because she's so quote and dela bleah
linked to the character and that they
ruled out actually using cgi so now they
have to go back to square one with a
script for Episode nine and Hamill
called Fisher quote irreplaceable as far
as he's concerned which is a good answer
I totally agree but but there apparently
was a petition to recast Leia with Meryl
Streep who was a longtime friend of
Carrie Fisher's it got eleven thousand
signatures but of course everyone that's
not how that's not how Hollywood works
people popular votes don't matter
they're just like people matter anywhere
else barely anyway what do you guys
think it JJ Abrams and the crew for
episode nine should do about this you
know cleanup crew right yeah and what
are what are some ways that you could
see the movie keeping general Leia
Organa as part of the story or maybe
explaining her absence in a way that
honors Carrie Fisher's memory is there a
right answer to this question this is
there's marker all over me that's right
anybody who has the perfect way to do
this will make a billion dollars and she
died a natural death
off screen just simple and move on per
second like okay so have her die off
screen so last time we see her at the
end of last Jedi clip yeah the spark
that ignites the flame telling ray that
we have everything we need and then
millennium falcon blasts off to some
other unknown rebel we have this tiny
amount left of the rebellion and she so
she there's a battle maybe somebody who
kind of thinking like do you think maybe
causes know
turns out her heart couldn't handle that
maneuver yeah it's it's tough right like
you don't I think something just like a
quick explanation in the opening crawl
would be too impersonal yeah I think you
would need to have some kind of moment
with the cat like I think it's some
other video I did I compared this to the
cars movies which you know Paul Newman
did the voice of doc and he passed away
between cars one cars too so they had to
like figure out a way well he's part of
the movies and they didn't want to bring
in another voice actor even though it's
you know it's you can't animation you
could bring in someone who could do a
Paul Newman impression they didn't want
to do that so what they ended up doing
the cars too sucked but cars three I
actually really liked trotted up
multiple times yeah they they what they
ended up doing is they made the story of
cars three thematically connected to the
lessons that doc tried to impart on
Lightning McQueen in the first Cars
movie but they acknowledge that he died
they acknowledge that he died didn't
explain how but they don't explain a lot
of things yeah right so as we all know
the alien bug creature that slithered
inside of the cars frame crawled out
into the desert and dried in the Arizona
heat that's that's how all these
creatures working no but I think they
could they could learn those lessons as
well for the last Jedi in that they
could they could use some of the lessons
that Leia Organa wanted to impart onto
characters like Poe and Rey and have the
whole movie Poe and Rey trying to learn
those lessons in their own light so that
the the spirit of Leah's message is able
to live on I think I don't know exactly
how that looks because it's still a
really hard thing as a writer to try to
like work on the page a lot of people
still break down it's like what she
would have wanted kind of dialog and you
used a lot of Kirk me who did the
obi-wan Kenobi in the original Alec
Guinness yeah they use his voice often
in other force awakens yeah for like a
second and like there may be a chance to
have her say some new dialogue based on
the they already started they're just
making random sentences right now to see
if it sounds like your pitch was a
funeral started yeah you're kind of
saying like maybe we don't necessarily
see if we don't see you a lot about
like leftovers the themes of it and you
you're saying goes Kingfisher anything
carry on 30 rock oh yeah cuz I have dumb
answers in my head so being respectful
to losing a great creative and what it
means to all the fans had maybe do a
force ghost but you like see your
shoulder it's something something like
that where you see like the buns like
you see something like that as like a
whatever Louet yes when you hear her
like you hear her voice like echo like
through people's memories but you open
with the funeral the funeral is like the
literally the best way you should do
this because you've shown a for the
story you saw honda you saw Luke died
but you don't need to show her dying you
can just show that she gave her life for
the cause and for some reason maybe a
battle maybe it's just natural causes
but um yeah I'm fine with that I'm
pretty unsure about my own feelings
about it but right now my gut is going
with you show some something that
results in her day okay she's kidnapped
by the Knights of Ren and she only
communicates via a hologram mmm all the
gram is over like a teddy bear or
something like it's not her though stone
it's kind of her but it's like a CG so
you don't even like see you got a lot
more flexibility because it's quite a
distorted or it's like bring in five but
then the Knights of Ren kill her yeah
yeah that's kind of a little what I'm
saying works like I think she needs to
die in a Star Wars movie when the hours
of the movie yeah have your beautiful
Leia mine and I think it could be the
lamest version but I could see them
doing it is it equivalent of on Alderaan
explosion where's like lay us on that
planet
I'm OD yeah I think no matter what the
episode 9 needs to still be about Leia
like it needs to be about where the
characters will and testament or
something like that and the way that
like the final chapter of the Harry
Potter stories was about Dumbledore like
we learned so much about Dumbledore even
though his character was gone like you
went into it was like the life of times
of Albus Dumbledore the Deathly Hallows
was so there's no reason why we can't do
that with leia here let's let's explore
let's let her
her legacy be the focus Sasori all
against recasting yeah I'm gonna be
honest
watching like Civil War an ant-man they
make Michael Douglas and Robert Downey
jr. look really like good as like maybe
one Tarkin is a little hard to look at
sometimes and also it feels wrong when
I'm watching what's crazy is you're like
nobody's face looks like that and then
you look at him again York oh my god he
is a man I get that but he doesn't look
like a face you know what he's back to
camera for a little while and you just
kind of go yeah that's his voice that's
what he sounds like but a straight away
it was like front on close-up hey yeah
it's right here and it's only it's all
fake that's real they got real in banana
in Brooklyn's case that was [ __ ]
ambitious that word comes back the John
Knoll who's a you know a Lucasfilm guy
pitched that movie and I think part of
his pitch was like I'm gonna bring
competitive and that's like he's like
I'm gonna be able to do things with CGI
trust me as a visual effects guy
everybody all right well let's move on
to another quick update from the news
this week John Krasinski who of course
played Jim on the office said in an
interview that he would love to play mr.
fantastic Reed Richards in a Fantastic
Four movie oh we got like a Photoshop
mock-up there kind of looks like the
Avengers logo without the halo
okay and now of course Krasinski stars
in and directed the amazing horror film
a quiet place it comes out this weekend
alongside his real-life wife Emily Blunt
whom he said he would love to play The
Invisible Woman Sue Storm moving
Dreamcast see me
we just got right there to remind
everybody John Krasinski has been trying
to be in a superhero movie since the
office yeah right after the office he
was like you know I'd love to be a
superhero any movie that that casting
has been like like now it's like oh
they're considered people he's been in
the running
he came really close he was almost cap
yeah all the way back then yeah which
I'm glad with Chris Evans but yeah and
then he also maybe came close on Shazam
maybe for that yeah I mean he's an
athlete he played basketball in high
school yeah unfortunately the dream role
loving be it he's got a great beard
throw a little salt and pepper in there
there you go now he's saving the
universe stretching all over the place
burn some airplanes in the background
yeah okay everyone Rick and Morty fans
were thrown a bone this week during
their long open-ended wait for season
four in the form of another Adult Swim
April Fool's prank last year Justin
roiland and Dan Harmon released the
season three premiere episode this year
it was a parody episode called bush
world adventures amazing this our
reimagining of the show created by
Australian animator Michael Cusack who
made this the popular youtube series
demo and Darren damodaran
and animated last months Rick and Morty
themed run the jewels music video that
was awesome so yes obviously bush world
adventures is not a Rick and Morty
episode it's not canon the characters
look way different they have creepy
eyelids Rick is crazy jacked
Roland isn't doing the voices obviously
everyone's just an extreme version of
themselves that keeps referencing
Australian stuff
Rick takes Morty on a trip to the
Australian city of
to find his green cube during which they
cross paths with a bush wizard who looks
like Jerry but isn't but then it is kind
of and then they also be the giant named
uncle Barry and well and yeah if you
just want to see Rick scream at Morty
and put him in danger and sexually
humiliate him and make a few meta
references to Rick's disrespect of
bureaucrats and well-beloved of an
accidental giant murder and sons with
scary faces and you know gross gross a
little call back to the original doc and
Marty pilot if you if you really know
you're Rick and Morty history this is
definitely fun to watch
it might make you miss the show which is
not actually had its fourth season
officially approved yet by Adult Swim
Justin roiland tweeted saying that they
were just waiting on the network to find
more ways to make money from the series
more how are you making money from it's
the biggest day before head I don't know
yeah and there's so much merch already
out there okay well the mayor of Bendigo
in real life that was a destination in
this episode has was shown Bush world
adventure adventures and she wasn't
familiar with Rick and Morty and she
said she was quite staggered by the
vulgar humor and after Google search
results for the city shot up after this
episode she admitted that any publicity
is good publicity but that Bendigo is
nothing like what was displayed in the
episode is basic kind of boring
it was like a barren wasteland now
Cusack admits that he was he's never
actually been to the city he just picked
Bendigo because the name sounded funny
[Music]
yeah okay and if anything would buy your
ankle first Bush world adventures what'd
you guys think of this episode did it
live up to your Rick and Morty
expectations it scared me more than most
of them yeah it's great though it's like
look I'm a you my body left and it
wouldn't are you or whatever he's saying
cute that's a you like Kate to be Fraser
some of the Australian you barely hear
the - he's like the you yeah you go jump
in the you know you it's there
listen you what is it a car it's short
for utility utility utility truck you
don't even know you're asking the truck
YouTube utility so it's a that's why the
SUV the sports utility vehicle the sea
patrol being a big truck you can
actually get a smaller like the outback
actually is designed that way to have it
okay that just connected for me yeah
there's a card called the outback Oh
huge for me this felt like what I
imagine people who don't really like
Ricky Moore do don't ever watch it is
for every episode of Ricky morning with
just like it's just like this old man
screaming at a little boy and trying to
kill them and there's a lot of
understood everything and everything
even if they sometimes might well we
don't really use truth as much anymore
my pay respects but when it gets weird I
mean that's why people love Rick and
Morty my it's right I don't like it no
my god I did not like this I did not
care for it I love Rick and Morty I
liked about five minutes of this and
then the 11 I know
oh yeah well honestly it's like
absurdist humor like yeah be very hit or
miss for me at least and so he grabbed
wait did he grab on you little soft yeah
like around there and but also it's like
five minutes of a very clear game that I
think is very funny which is the idea
that for those first five or six minutes
it was also like is Rick not good at
science and like it's all in his head
cuz he's like they will go to another
dimension but it's like down the street
and like his portal gonna just
gun and I thought that was a really fun
thing with this idea that like Oh Rick
just thinks that it like all this like
adventure stuff is happening but he's
just a crazy man exactly yeah but then
eventually like no he does have stuff
and there are portals and stuff and it
just kind of like lost some inspiration
I just went anywhere the dougie part in
the begin in the middle with like the
grub and everything that that was like
the least interesting part and then when
he got to his uncle Barry like that got
fun again and it didn't ended kind of
strong I mean he's dead
like this you have to like really really
love troll humor like just a troll just
like and we know what the joke is and
we're just like making fun of it now and
Rick and Morty does do a lot of the real
series does a lot of that and sometimes
they're really great about it sometimes
I think especially in season 3 there
were times where it's like okay you've
done like too much of it like 30% the
episode is that now when like I think
the writers just start to get a little
bored with their own premise and I think
this is all of that so I appreciate that
was only 11 minutes long because I think
any longer I think also part of the
problem is that they're doing it to Rick
and Morty or something right some it's a
little bit more like traditional and
straightforward but still very comedic
but they're like imagine the Simpsons
went off the rails
it's like become Morty goes off the
rails like yeah it already does what if
it didn't have rules though or story or
structure or anything this is it's not
what you never would ask for that but
that's what that we get that's where we
got yeah but I love seeing it on stuff
that you wouldn't expect it from it's
better that way yeah you know what the
quiz should have been what is Rick
holding in his hand
oh wait Cousy no no I know I know I know
I know what it is it's it's a it's a
it's not stuffy cooler and that's why
I'd be cooler is what it's stubby is the
American word for the the same thing you
just said - cool it's a Bakula yeah the
American the cool one Cousy
yeah I think ours is actually the
weirder
you can't say cousin
India well let us know what you thought
about this Bush World Adventures Rick
and Morty episode do you think it can
sustain you through the next two to
eight years before another season comes
well reminded this in the cab reminded
to describe subscribe to New York stars
for all of our Rick and Morty coverage
we actually did breakdowns of all the
episodes of season three and a bunch of
other videos about jokes that you might
have missed but knowing Rick and Maury
fans you need miss anything anyway okay
but you know now it's time to move on to
our new rock stars news questions thank
you for tweeting us these questions I'm
gonna fire them at my co-hosts who have
to answer them as quickly and without as
hesitation as as possible this is gonna
close your eyes you always send me ones
there's like here recast this whole TV
series go with Maude at that Lily Mason
wants to know which non-powered
non-magical superhero would you want to
have your back in a fight some are just
like super super people all right
smackle dub ed nice what's it know
should play Jason Todd if slash win the
DCE who doesn't under the Red Hood
I always liked Jensen Ackles performance
of Jason Todd and he would work fine for
the Aged like he played you could play
young enough for mid to like like
mid-20s season 39 he's starting to look
a little seasoned 15 14 13 I don't know
where they're at
I want him because I like he's got a I
like what he's got going on
with that deal and I Brian it sounds
good
Santos Jay black wants to know if you
could make a musical out of either DCU
MCU The Walking Dead or Game of Thrones
which would it be and who would you cast
is your leading man or lady uh okay
I want the answer to be Game of Thrones
because a game of Thrones musical would
be so good but they like like like
that's just like being a fan thing like
sure they would never actually do it I
could actually see them doing them I
could actually see them doing a Marvel
musical somehow I especially because the
DC did have one on the flash and it was
five it was good because it's a musical
and it's fun but daring Chris was there
okay but from that I would take Jeremy
Jordan who is win on Supergirl it was
one of the best singers in the world
last five years yeah Jeremy Jordan
singing Celine Dion what's the song who
knows it's so good that my heart will go
on
No and Jimmy Jordan maybe a Silver
Surfer oh yeah and he could kid The
Avengers have to fight him but he makes
them sing all coming back to me yes yeah
I've seen that is that even below is
that the New York Bar it's so good the
end all right and uh for me Philip I
gave you three different options so does
it look like a creep
[Music]
of what show your walking dead yeah yeah
yeah blurred out Eric where's a Walking
Dead headed who's gonna die next at it's
Deb t82
who's gonna die next at the end of this
season
hmm okay so I would say I think that
Dwight Dwight I think Dwight is gonna
die next season I think for a into the
comics I think we're gonna see the
Commonwealth from recent run little
comics a new group coming in that seems
a little bit like the Commonwealth it's
very advanced very very advanced they
I've got a concert arena it's some
musical episode of Walking Dead in there
and lightning round tweet next week
where we'll where we'll get to all your
questions eventually okay but next let
us take a look at what we got in the
pipeline for videos coming out on this
channel in the next week for a sauce
weekend Walking Dead we will do a
breakdown of episode 15 the penultimate
episode of the season
I can't wait because there's a fear The
Walking Dead crossover episode is our
finale and it sounds like fear The
Walking Dead might be coming up nipping
at the heels right now that shows fear
The Walking Dead as a Western yeah the
trailer for that played a wunderkind
it looks very cool it looked it was more
exciting than anything from recently The
Walking Dead I've seen we also got a MCU
rewatched series going on to do it's
good do catch America Civil War it's a
very good movie I would show you talk
about with all these lying folk I love
how the movie starts with all of the
strongest superheroes in a hotel room
and all the weakest sar kind of like the
ones that are trying to save things
you'll see you'll see yeah no spoilers
we also have some more infinity war
context it can't wait for this movie
yeah but Philip talked about this
earlier we're gonna be doing a video on
Hawkeye
we also want to look into so we love
looking at danos from the comics and
what precedent he has and how that might
be adapted the movie so we want to look
at like who had who does Stannis have a
history of murdering in the comics he
kills like everybody right so what's
really cool I think in that video we'll
get into how he kills them because when
you have the gauntlet
you can kill in so many creative birds
the Cyclops death is the one personally
I think that's the one that he get a box
gets around his head right when the
laser goes off he like what do ya'll
sorry I can't breathe he's like yeah
there's all sorts of creativity there
yeah the writers had a lot of fun
literally well now comes the time for
our 15-second shout-out where each of us
has 15 seconds to shout out plug or
ramble about anything we want Sam now
you said okay two things one a quiet
place go see it it's amazing if you like
thrillers it's definitely up your alley
also my new favorite meme is just search
a screaming cowboy and if you find a
thumbnail of a cowboy in the mountains
screaming I've been playing that
non-stop for a couple days it's been
great thank you for my 15 stick and
shout out a lot have you been tweeting
me about this already but for those of
you haven't Legion season 2 premiered
this past week I love that show favorite
show I wish we had more time to do more
videos about hopefully we'll have time
to do a video come we won't be doing
episode by episode breakdown stop
tweeting me about it we don't have time
to do we have stew much on a calendar
but watch the show it's mine are a why
the last man it's an old graphic novel
but they're finally making the pilot so
go read the graphic novel real quick
because they'll never kind of be able to
like fully do that but it's the last man
on earth are surrounded by women also
the writers are women and the directors
yeah yeah it's so cool I've been Devin
what's your what's the video game of the
new spider-man game yeah and they just
drop a little bit of
cool footage on that yeah I'm going
video games as well I'm playing Steve
thieves I'm so good at it can you add me
into rocks I can't stop it
this person's like doing all the
challenges and I'm just like cut I can't
even get past a rock or something anyway
yeah see if these guys
well great yeah check out all those
things and finally let's return to the
trivia question that we asked earlier
yeah just to remind you of what the
question was
we'll take this one question was in
Doctor Strange when Stephen strange
arrives that come our Taj what is the
Wi-Fi password that Mordo gives him
let's take a look at what we said
interesting
Eric Eric said Val tor V alt Orr being a
nurse what is that I think it's like
some some phrase from them here's my my
frustration with Eric we broke down the
hell out of this trailer and this joke
was in a trailer so many times and we
also broke us out yeah
and this wrote laughs does that help Sam
says a sorry shangri-la shangri-la
shangri-la
I know spelling pepper because I didn't
know if I finger right port that the
heavy elite numbering believe in magic
like super sweet no it's the Wi-Fi
password
and then you say and then the easier
threes these don't work don't use its
Sam Bachelor familiar the heaven the
other habit for me I think I'm pretty
close actually
the answer is Shambhala the farthest
away winner would be Sam yeah yeah
Simba oh sorry I meant to say Philip
yeah but yeah
alright so Philip is our winner okay our
loser is I'm funny that was funny
your body didn't you write you write for
your Twitter tour and honestly it's a
dr. strange word thank believe in magic
with threes that's not a word I'm gonna
call you out I think you wanted to lose
I think you think your jokes are gonna
be so good this week okay well there are
goodbyes Phillip will get to do that the
kind of way to do it like a joke answer
that's still one like that was great
that's impressive
there are headlines and be funny and
yeah Maude would you like to read the
headline to set it up so I'll have time
to think
all righty
in other news Joe Manganiello I said
that a Deathstroke movie is still in the
works despite the character and
development struggles yep did I miss the
word no it's written weird
despite the character development
struggles in the Batman solo movie I am
will need a need a Magic Mike miracle to
save that character
it's not a verb and you say yourself up
minute or do you say minute or a minute
oh I mean the first one tor no one says
- why no man I'll show ya tell you
there's always someone she's in
Australia - I think you're just faking a
lot of minority number - stranger things
created a toughie brothers being sued by
filmmaker he claims they stole ideas
from his short film a claim that the
duffer's have denied the judges ruled
that the lawsuit is fraudulent unless
the directors last name is spielberg
magic miracle hey number three is coming
along Zack Snyder said that in Batman V
Superman Bruce Wayne uses sex as a drug
to numb himself from his emotional pain
if that movie wasn't fun enough well
check this out
kids I used the movie Batman vs Superman
to numb myself from the pain of watching
it I can't say that after and now that I
have to be funny it's a different this
isn't me this is what the hell Zack
Snyder talking about that did not happen
in that movie so old now just live in
Louisville all right here we go take the
[ __ ] open the giant what is it a phoenix
tattoo on you he's going through zone
it's written in the feather Jeffrey Dean
Morgan just happening what a day more
named Rob and my back's all from picking
them all up as well Jeffrey Dean Morgan
said in an interview that the movie
Watchmen was ahead of its time
and denied rumors that the movie was a
bunch of holy crap I could see your body
shifting watchman's a bad movie no
Batman solo movie will not focus on the
death of Jason Todd Robin contrary to
fans rumors rumors okay no Jason time no
done to Jeffrey Dean Morgan yeah I guess
where'd I go just then that was fun hey
yeah oh and it was all hell's warm and
yeah all right Philip take it take it
away your goodbyes
guys I we just need to end this episode
goodbye you guys thanks for watching
this week
I think our host Sam bash at Sam
bachelor at Eric or Eric boss a TA vos
he's killed himself first
Phil Molina at fimo and Maude Garrett at
Maude Garrett also make sure to check
out keep bomb because it sounds like
she's gonna do a lot more than just name
drop their SH boy drop some videos uh
Amy's comment down below on any of the
stuff we talked about this episode and
tweet us at new rock stars hey you can't
even play dead I like this video and
share it around to your friends and
subscribe to new rock stars if you don't
subscribe and you're this far and you're
asleep and that's really the only way
thanks for the video
can't even play alright we got a lot of
deep dives coming up on stuff you love
we'll see you guys next week
[Music]